our hearts and minds still with Kobe
Bryant his family after that tragic
accident and we have new reporting on
how his wife Vanessa is coping with this
unimaginable loss you guys are on a lot
of red carpet which is very fortunate
and blessed to have two you know healthy
children and I'd like to go for someone
this is a really historic moment I'm so
happy for him this is such an honor for
him
Vanessa feels almost numb to everything
that's what a family source tells us
today adding she is completely shocked
and heartbroken but is trying to stay as
strong as she can in front of her
children Vanessa and Kobe married nearly
19 years ago vanessa was just 18 years
old and quote never expected to live her
life without him this morning Vanessa
changed her Instagram profile pic to
this image of Kobe and their daughter
Gianna who also died in the crash we're
told right now Vanessa's taking time to
be with her girls while Vanessa focuses
on family there are new clues today
about what may have caused the crash the
descent rate for the helicopter was over
2,000 feet a minute so we know that this
was a high-energy impact crash
investigators airlifted the wreckage of
Kobe Sikorsky s-76 B from the hillside
what remained of the chopper was then
transported by truck to a secure
location investigators also recovered
the bodies of all nine victims we were
able to recover an iPad and a cell phone
the NTSB says the luxury chopper was
missing a vital warning system that
could have helped prevent the crash
I was asked about terrain awareness and
warning systems which provides terrain
information to the pilot I was asked
whether that was on this helicopter we
have verified it was not and this might
come as a comfort to Kobe's fans the NBA
champion was at peace with confronting
his own mortality
he thought about it in 2016 while
grappling with whether or not he should
retire what
relationship with death it's a
comfortable one it's an understanding
can't have life without death can't have
light without the dark right so it's an
acceptance of that we take stuff and
rabbit shack was overcome with grief
last night as he and a few MBA greats
turned what was supposed to be game
coverage into a moving tribute the fact
that uh we're not gonna be able
Joe get his Hall of Fame ceremony though
for the baby
can't get back calling Coby his little
brother Shaq also addressed all the talk
about their feud I don't want to hear
about the beef that y'all thought we had
this man knows our true relationship
their worship did this say something to
him yeah it took a lot of people in my
life
Rick Fox addressed the early reports
that had him on Kobe's helicopter when
it went down my phone just started going
in my mom and my sister and my brother
and some buddies apparently told him
that I may have been on the helicopter
my family went through in the midst of
all of this something I couldn't have
imagined them experiencing he was
enjoying life and went way too way too
early Toby would want us all to carry on
and be great in our lives you know we
should do something great because he was
such a great man great husband and great
father and that father was beaming in
our last interview talking about his
daughters three beautiful healthy you
know young ladies and with another one
on the way so we're just just very very
fortunate he said I would have five more
girls if I could I'm a girl dad after
ESPN's Elle Duncan paid tribute stars
including a rod Al Roker Russell Wilson
and morph got the hashtag girl dad
trending such a loss dad and director
Ron Howard at the TV Academy Hall of
Fame event shared with et a lighter
moment he had meeting the first time
Oscar winner I had to say look respect
to you but I I got I gotta give you some
grief because your make you making it
look a little too easy my friend
rookie I said I got to treat you like
the rookie who got off to a great start
[Music]